watch this is just perfect this is
perfect government 101 here is uh John
Kirby who has become sort of the most
you know Corinne Jean-Pierre is like the
obvious clown of the administration but
he is running a really tight second
right now and just making up nonsense
watch this let me ask you about the F-35
how does the US military lose a 100
million dollar plane that will be
something that they will investigate the
believe me after every Aviation mishap
the Pentagon does what the Pentagon does
they'll investigate it to try to get the
answers on what happened and they'll
also I'm sure look at their own search
and Recovery efforts of the aircraft
itself to see whether that was conducted
in in all the appropriate ways they'll
they'll investigate this and as the
defense department always does they'll
be transparent about it when they when
they find the answer oh well they'll be
transparent I mean this is the
government forgot like if my guys lost a
piece of equipment a camera if a camera
was missing from my studio all hell
would be breaking loose until it would
be found okay and it's like Jeffrey
it's just perfect he's perfect right
he's perfect bureaucrat right now he's
perfect you know and I've never been a
big fan of government uh I've never been
hugely trusting of government but these
days uh it's a different level you know
I just assume that anything coming out
of these people's mouths is is just is
completely uh you know made up to to
cover up and the idea of the Department
of Defense being transparent you know
the Department of Defense was involved
very deeply in the coveted response we
still cannot get a fix on that I would
love to see some transparency there
mishap though boy that word is so that's
their talking point that's the word they
keep repeating there's something
embedded in that word mishap foreign